bonjour Marc phénom merci d'être avec
nous on dirait que vous êtes ministre de
de l'agriculture je résume ce que disait
il y a quelques instants Julien Legay
sur place cette canalisation allait bien
servir pour alimenter cette bassine et
en gros ce n'est que le début des
opérations
excusez-moi de vous dire que je trouve
ça assez lunaire d'entendre des propos
comme cela d'abord parce que ce monsieur
a l'air de ne pas savoir précisément à
quoi va servir
cet ouvrage deuxièmement faut pas
négliger le fait qu'il a détruit un bien
un coup de pelle de pioche un coup de je
ne sais quoi et donc il a détruit un
bien qui est légalement installé dans un
projet qui est l'égalité légalement
décidé donc une forme d'apologie de la
violence et du on fait ce qu'on veut
dans des projets qui sont
démocratiquement installés il y a
quelque chose de très choquant si chacun
va chez le voisin il aime pas le projet
et qui va détruire dans quelle
démocratie on y a pas envie depuis en
démocratie parce que c'est la loi du
plus fort qui s'impose et moi je
voudrais quand même saluer les forces de
l'ordre présente depuis deux jours enfin
un peu plus même d'ailleurs pour
protéger parce que vous voyez bien que à
chaque instant le seul objectif de notre
cible enfin il y a des mots qui sont
utilisés et qui sont les mots de la
violence et puis au-delà des mots de la
violence il y a la violence extrême
elle-même qui se
met en place qui est extrême et qui se
met en place à l'endroit d'installation
qui sont légalement installés et donc il
y a il y a c'est assez lunaire
d'entendre quelqu'un vous expliquer ça
sans dire par ailleurs que le projet
était validé que deux ça va produire de
l'économie d'eau dans les périodes qui
sont les périodes difficiles qui sont
des périodes estivales avec une forme de
caricature qui pour moi pas acceptable
ce que disent les participants sur place
et puis des des représentants politiques
plutôt dans l'opposition c'est que c'est
aussi la présence de ce dispositif
extrêmement important 1600 gendarmes qui
est à l'origine de la tension à
l'origine des violences ça c'est la
vieille dialectique de ceux qui disent
qui viennent parce que je rappelle les
moteurs le mot d'ordre c'était un de
destruction d'ouvrages et d'ailleurs la
preuve en est cet après-midi
si dès qu'ils ont pu échapper un peu aux
forces de l'ordre ils ont décidé de
détruire donc pardon excusez-moi faut
pas inverser le sens des choses les
forces de l'ordre elles sont là pour
maintenir l'ordre républicain elles sont
pas là pour autre chose et d'ailleurs
c'est ce qu'elles font en permanence et
ce qu'elles ont essayé depuis 3 jours
sur le site et donc inverser les rôles
quand j'entends certains parlementaires
dire que c'est une manifestation
pacifique et que c'est de la
désobéissance Pacifique tout le monde
aura vu les images aujourd'hui et hier
de quel côté était la violence et quels
étaient manifestement les volontés
violentes de ceux qui étaient sur le
terrain
je vous coupe juste parce que ça c'était
le sens d'un tweet des Jean-Luc
Mélenchon ce midi dans BFM politique
c'est à Sandrine Rousseau la députée
europécologie les Verts qui étaient
l'invité de Jean-Baptiste boursier elle
appelle à la désobéissance sans violence
est-ce que vous condamnez ces propos
d'une élue de la République mais c'est
surtout une hypocrisie totale c'est
c'est illégal et c'est avec violence
donc les mots à rien madame Rousseau dit
des choses elle a même justifié le fait
qu'on vient de dégrader le véhicule d'un
de ses propres amis monsieur monsieur
Jadot donc vous voyez bien dans quel
dans quel hypocrisie on est quand on va
participer à une manifestation qui a été
interdite parce qu'on savait qu'il y
avait des éléments violents qui étaient
dedans et quand vous voyez l'arsenal qui
a été retrouvé ils étaient pas là pour
pour faire une kermesse manifestement et
puis deuxième élément quand on est un
responsable public madame Rousseau ou
d'autres on ne dit pas des choses qui
sont exactement inverse de la vérité il
y a des actes de violence il y a eu je
le répète même des actes violences sur
un de ses amis et elle manifestement ça
avait pas l'air de la gêner expliquant
que Monsieur Jadot avait pas bien
compris ce que était les nouvelles
formes de radicalité mais si la
radicalité c'est détruire le bien
d'autrui c'est évidemment quelque chose
qui est inacceptable en démocratie il y
a moins que on décide de changer de
régime on est sur une bassine dans les
Deux-Sèvres il y a plusieurs projets de
de bassine 16 si ma mémoire est bonne
est-ce qu'on risque d'assister 16 fois à
ce spectacle à se fasse face à face
malheureusement j'ai l'impression qu'un
certain nombre de gens ont décidé d'en
découdre c'est une ultra minorité mais
très violente et donc très visible moi
je demande simplement qu'on regarde ces
projets dans la réalité de ce qu'ils
sont il y a des engagements de réduction
des prélèvements d'eau il y a des
engagements des agriculteurs de
réduction d'utilisation des produits
phytosanitaires il y a depuis un certain
temps dans ces territoires là une
réduction des surfaces en maïs donc au
lieu d'être dans le postulat et
dogmatisme parce que sans eau il n'y a
pas d'agriculture alors si ces gens-là
n'ont qu'autre choix de nous dire que
faut pas d'agriculture qui l'assument
mais il me semble que sur des projets
qui sont légalement installés qui ont
fait l'objet de tous les recours
possibles qui ont été parfois discutés y
compris avec les associations
environnementales un certain nombre
d'entre elles avaient avec donné leur
accord à ce là et si on en fait si après
alors après on est dans un dans un
régime qui ne fonctionne plus et donc on
a besoin de reposer tranquillement
autant que faire se peut ces questions
d'eau il y a besoin d'eau pour l'eau
potable pour l'agriculture pour soutenir
les étiages pour lutter contre les
inondations on a besoin d'ouvrages aussi
pour lutter contre les incendies et donc
c'est plutôt des solutions que je
cherche que de la violence en permanence
sur le terrain hors manifestement il y a
des gens qui ont fait le choix de la
violence juste une dernière question
est-ce qu'il n'y a pas d'autres
solutions que sébacine les gens qui sont
sur le terrain des agriculteurs
notamment je parle pas de militants à
Guy mais agriculteurs disent que ça
avantage les gros exploitations et pas
les agriculteurs donc qui sont à la tête
d'exploitation de revenus plus modestes
quel est votre réponse à cette remarque
mais c'est inexact parce que moi je
connais des tas d'agriculteurs qui ont
besoin d'eau et qui accèdent à l'eau
dans des tas d'ouvrages et donc l'idée
de dire et de caricaturer une fois de
plus il y a plus de 400 agriculteurs si
j'ai pas de mémoire qui sont engagés
dans ce projet de coopérative donc c'est
pas nécessaire de gros et petit c'est
une affaire d'avoir accès à l'eau et
certains ont besoin de plus d'eau parce
qu'ils ont plus de surface que d'autres
mais c'est ce procès qui est en
privatisation ou en utilisation par un
seul petit nombre par ailleurs je
rappelle que l'écrase et les
autorisations de prélèvement d'eau sont
délivrés par la puissance publique donc
ça n'est pas une privatisation puisque
c'est la puissance publique qui
autorisera ou non tel ou tel prélèvement
d'eau en fonction c'est donc pas du tout
un projet privé c'est un projet qui est
complètement sous le sous le dialogue et
sous la responsabilité de la puissance
publique et donc c'est cette affaire de
privatisation des gros contre les
privatisation du public contre le purisé
est une affaire fausse elle aussi merci
beaucoup Marcello ministre de la vie
quelques instants cet après-midi